[Musik]
der us-präsident im krankenhaus die
first lady alleine im weißen haus und
die engsten mitarbeiter des
us-präsidenten untereinander zerstritten
und einige von ihnen mit einem virus
infiziert nein das ist nicht house of
cards das ist die welt in der wir leben
und darüber wollen wir heute abend
sprechen hierbei die richtigen fragen
über den us präsidenten donald trump und
seine krone infektion unter anderem mit
dem deutschen aussenminister heiko maas
und einem der engsten vertrauten von
donald trump dem ehemaligen
us-botschafter hier in berlin
regional uns heute abend zugeschaltet
aus kalifornien viel spaß bei die
richtigen fragen
[Musik]
21.45 am sonntagabend herzlich
willkommen hier bei bild bei die
richtigen fragen mit spannenden gästen
zu einem thema das derzeit die ganze
welt bewegt bei uns heute abend ist der
deutsche außenminister heiko maas frisch
zurück aus der korona quarantäne
herzlich willkommen ebenfalls bei uns
fred pleitgen cnn-korrespondent hier in
berlin und natürlich amerika kenner
herzlich willkommen
der kann man kann sagen legendäre
gastgeber der münchner
sicherheitskonferenz herr herzlich
willkommen heute abend hierbei die
richtigen fragen in berlin aus basel ist
uns zugeschaltet die journalistin tamara
wernli kolumnistin unter anderem für die
weltwoche und aus dem fernen kalifornien
zugeschaltet der ehemalige deutsche der
ehemalige amerikanische botschafter hier
in berlin
mcconnell kultivierte california soll
wir wollen erst einmal anfangen mit
ihnen herr maas sie sind sozusagen
frisch zurück aus der quarantäne sie
waren zwei wochen war sie verschwunden
warum waren sie so lange weg sie hatten
wir müssen sie einmal klarstellen sie
hatten nicht corona aber sie mussten
zwei wochen in quarantäne
warum nehmen das ist so ich bin ende
zwei wochen dreimal getestet worden weil
man negativ aber die regel ist so wie
man mit einer infizierten person
unmittelbar kontakt hatte das war einer
meiner sicherheitsbeamten
dann geht die 14 tage regel egal wie oft
man positiv getestet worden ist und die
habe ich dann auch abgesessen sozusagen
bin froh dass es vorbei ist
habe mich selten so gefreut bei der bild
zeitung zu sein weil ich das freut uns
natürlich zu hören rick wir wollen wir
einmal ansprechen in kalifornien
am anderen ende der welt sozusagen einer
der engsten vertrauten von us-präsident
vom was können sie uns herr botschafter
erzählen über den gesundheitszustand des
us präsidenten
danke für die einladung ich bin hier in
kalifornien ihr ja in pennsylvania herrn
der wahlkampftour in ohio elevator in
washington state in oracle
ich hatte die möglichkeit mit dem
stabschef marc mertens zu sprechen sowie
auch mit dem nationalen
sicherheitsberater
einige male der präsident ist in guter
stimmung er hatte leichte symptome
es gibt ihm ziemlich gut er arbeitet
ich glaube ist übervorsichtig man
betreuten mit größter vorsicht
er ist in sehr guter stimmung und es
geht ihm sehr gut wir haben in den
letzten tagen verschiedene dinge über
den gesundheitszustand von den fans
gehört selbst von seinen ärzten heute
hieß es er könnte sogar montag wieder
zurück im büro sein requiem glauben sie
dass er tatsächlich morgen wieder im
oval office sitzt
ich habe jetzt ein bisschen probleme mit
dem hören des tons ich glaube aber der
präsident wird so bald als möglich ist
wieder voll an der arbeit sein er hat
großes vertrauen in die ärzte erdrückt
natürlich auf die tube ich möchte
möglichst schnell wieder zurück an meine
arbeitsstätten und ich glaube er wird
alles tun um das zu malen über den
gesundheitszustand des us präsidenten
mit einem weiteren zugeschalteten gast
sprechen mit dem biologen professor
hendrik speck henry gestrickt ist einer
der großen topf logan der in dieser
kurve der uns durch diese kroner zeit
begleitet hat und er war unter anderem
tätig am krankenhaus wollte reid in dem
sich der us präsident
derzeit befindet guten abend nach
hamburg professor strickt sie haben als
experte sozusagen die bilder von donald
trump natürlich auch verfolgt in den
letzten tagen zum beispiel das video was
er heute gepostet hat wie wirkt der
us-präsident auf sie das schönen guten
abend erreichen
insgesamt wirkt der eigentlich wie viele
der patienten die man mit 19 sieht mit
einem eher milden verlauf man hört ein
wenig eine kurze öffnungszeiten ein
bisschen belegte stimme was auch dafür
spricht dass er die behandlung
er bekommt also wo er eben beschrieben
wurde auch für eine zeitlang sauerstoff
bekommen hat aber insgesamt scheint er
zumindest in dem video was ich gesehen
habe ein sehr guter dinge zu sein und
keinen schweren verlauf natürlich zu
haben
sie haben ihn geschrieben wir wollen das
unseren zuschauern auch einmal ganz kurz
zeigen was sie da beschrieben haben
dieser auftritt von us präsident donald
trump in einem video das er auf twitter
gepostet hat heute das schauen wir uns
jetzt einmal an
ich kam hier an und ich habe mich nicht
besonders gut gefühlt jetzt fühle ich
mich viel besser
alle arbeiten hart daran dass ich
zurückkomme und ich muss zurückkommen
für unser ziel amerika wieder großartig
zu machen da haben wir bis jetzt schon
einen richtig guten job gemacht aber es
bleibt schon noch einiges zu tun und
deshalb werde ich zurück sein
ja noch einmal zu henrik schräg wir
haben gehört dass der us-präsident
experimentelle vollkommen neue und noch
nicht zugelassene medikamente bekommen
hat unter anderem rem diese wir aber
auch ein weiteres medikament das nur bei
schweren verläufen gegeben wird worauf
deutet das hin dass man dem
us-präsidenten dieses revier gibt das
überraschende daran eigentlich waren
zwei dinge in der handlung einmal dass
eine regierung bekommen hat das ist ein
antikörper behandlung die derzeit in
einer klinischen studie sich zu finden
bei dieser bei diesem bitte handelt es
sich eigentlich um zwei ganzen körper
die sehr starke wirkung gegen das hat
bei uns haben und in klinischen studien
sehr gut aussehen also der gute wirkung
zeigen aber sie ist irgendwie gesagt
noch nicht zugelassen und daher ist es
unmöglich dass so was bereits eingesetzt
zusätzlich neben reserviert was auch in
leichter form bei leichten formen
eingesetzt wird liegt aber auch noch
extra meter sohn das ist ein fortis wohn
und das ist meistens dann gegeben
zumindest in deutschland aber auch in
den usa beim größten wo eine sauerstoff
darauf hört wie kabarett reihe zeigt das
dach einen positiven einfluss auf die
union hat was aber darauf deutet dass er
doch ja auch extern sauerstoff
angewiesen ist zurzeit das möchte ich
noch einmal kurz weitergeben nach
kalifornien an rené wir haben in den
letzten tagen berichte gelesen und
gehört in den donald trump als er gehört
hat von seiner infektion jedoch
tatsächlich in sorge war um seinen
eigenen zustand und tatsächlich gefragt
haben soll
ob es ihm so ergehen könnte wie einem
freund einem new yorker freund der an
cholera gestorben ist was können sie uns
als jemand der den präsidenten sehr gut
kennt sagen über den zu über den
mentalen zustand von donald trump in
diesen tagen wie geht er mit dieser
erkrankung um
wie ich schon vorhin gesagt
der präsident konzentriert sich darauf
die arbeit für das amerikanische volk zu
leisten er ist eine außerordentlich
robust dafür milde symptome und ich
denke man sollte jetzt in der
öffentlichkeit keine informationen
austauschen die einfach nicht da sind
wir sind alle überzeugt dem präsidenten
geht es sehr gut und was um ihn herum
geschieht ist das äußerste vorsicht und
sorgfalt angewandt wird um ihn so zu
überwachen so dass es zu keiner änderung
zum schlechteren kommt tatsache ist
viele menschen ziehen sich topfit und es
geht ihnen eigentlich nur gut sie aber
nur kleine grippesymptome es gibt einen
kleinen trotz einsatz von infizierten
denen es nicht so gut
vorsicht gebiete es also dass man den
präsidenten so überwachte er ist in
bester stürmer in typischer donald trump
ist der eben wirklich ganz heiß darauf
wieder zu arbeiten die ärzte sagen er
sollte vorsichtig sein
in einer in einem hollywood drehbuch zu
leben bei dem was in den letzten 6 9
monaten passiert ist ein virus aus china
geht um die welt tötet eine millionen
menschen und auf dem höhepunkt des us
wahlkampfs mit auf einmal der
us-präsident selber gefallen und ist nun
im krankenhaus im walter reed dorthin
geflogen worden vom weißen haus das ist
tatsächlich alles etwas was man
vermutlich bei house of cards wenn man
es da gesehen hätte er nicht geglaubt
hätte wie haben sie die letzten tage
wahrgenommen und vor allem was glauben
sie wie das jetzt den wahlkampf von
donald trump oder die us-wahl insgesamt
verändern wird also wahrscheinlich wäre
ein solches drehbuch
zunächst wir präsident trump seiner frau
und den mitarbeitern die infiziert sind
alles gute dass er so schnell wie
möglich wieder gesund wird dann auch so
schnell wie möglich wieder ins weiße
haus zurückkehren kann
wie sich das auswirken wird auf die
präsidentschaftswahlen das kann ich
wirklich nicht beurteilen das müssen die
bürgerinnen und bürger in den
vereinigten staaten tun
ich hoffe dass der fokus nicht zu sehr
abgelenkt von dem um was es geht nämlich
wer hat welche vorstellungen zudem dazu
der zukunft der vereinigten staaten
aber ich glaube dass man zum
gegenwärtigen zeitpunkt das gar nicht
sagen kann was ich glaube ehrlich sind
auch diejenigen die behaupten das ist
wissen wie sie es auswirken wird die
wissen s wirklich auch nicht also das
wird möglicherweise durchaus noch mal
einiges durcheinander würde aber wie das
sein wird kann glaube ich keiner
beurteilen
deshalb wäre es gut wenn der präsident
so schnell wie möglich wieder gesund
wird auch zurückkehren kann in den
wahlkampf dass es auch noch mal
mindestens ein duell gibt mit seinem
herausforderer beiden damit sich die
wählerinnen selber ein bild machen
können wie sie sich dann anfang november
entscheiden
wolfgang ischinger hat sie sind ja auch
kenner der vereinigten staaten seit
vielen vielen jahren jahrzehnten haben
diverse wahlkämpfer dort beobachtet
begleitet so ein vermutlich wie wir alle
noch nicht was glauben sie wie werden
sich diese bilder die wir da gesehen
haben
von donald trump im krankenhaus aus dem
krankenhaus auswirkungen auf seine
situation auf die wahl in den usa ich
glaube herr gomez hat recht
alles was wir jetzt dazu sagen und was
amerikanische kommentatoren dazu sagen
ist hochgradig spekulativ ich denke für
uns ist eines wichtig amerika ist
außerhalb der europäischen union
unser wichtigster partner und verbündete
und wir müssen ein interesse daran haben
dass die amerikanische bevölkerung am
dritten november das gefühl hat wir
haben eine eine entscheidung treffen
können aufgrund eines stattgefundenen
wahlkampf in dem beide kontrahenten ihre
rolle spielen konnten und wo hoffentlich
hinterher nicht vorwürfe laut werden der
entweder des der manipulation oder der
der der mangelnden fairness also ich
denke das ist unser dringendes interesse
in der tat dass der präsident möglichst
schnell gesund wird und seinen wahlkampf
gegen oder mit joe biden fortsetzen kann
damit hinterher nicht
verschwörungstheoretiker geschichten
kursieren die die polarisierung in der
amerikanischen gesellschaft ja schon
schlimm genug ist nach dem urteil aller
beteiligten nicht noch weiter angefacht
wolfgang ischinger fürchtet möglichen
verschwörungstheorien wenn donald trump
nicht in den wahlkampf zurückkehren
sollte
durch seine erkrankung glauben sie dass
das duell in zwei wochen so stattfinden
kann wie geplant das zweite duell gegen
joe biden mit grenade scheint uns
derzeit nicht zuhören fragen wir also
dieselbe frage an denen es hier einen
korrespondenten vertreten jetzt jetzt
hat er uns gehört ja ich wusste nicht
dass die frage an mich gerichtet war
julia vielleicht darf ich nur soviel
sagen wir haben einmal verzögere
ich würde sagen sicherlich so viel wie
möglich wieder in den wahlkampf zurück
gekämpft das schöne an den wahlen in den
usa ist dass sie sehr lange dauern
die schwierigkeit ist natürlich jetzt
ihnen so dass es so lange dauert also
das kann nach beiden seiten hin
ausschlagen
wir beobachten das ist kein welcher mit
größter geduld es gibt sehr viele
erregte debatten über politische themen
die tatsache dass das jetzt gerade in
den letzten 30 tagen geschieht ist
natürlich nicht sehr spießig aber ich
glaube wir haben die technik die
wirklich nötig ist um die politischen
positionen beider kandidaten des
präsidenten trump und des demokratischen
kandidaten beiden auszuarbeiten so dass
der wähler wirklich sehen kann wo die
unterschiede liegen
und die unterschiedlichen politischen
positionen abwägen kann sie wörter und
wirklich rüberkommen die technik erlaubt
uns dass wir dürfen auch nicht vergessen
dass wir noch zwei weitere präsidenten
debatten haben und auch noch am mittwoch
eine weitere vizepräsidenten debatte
das heißt es gibt der reichlichen
gelegenheiten die unterschiedlichen am
mittwoch in sound like da wird der vize
präsident und kamera harris miteinander
diskutieren werden und die
unterschiedlichen politischen
standpunkte darlegen werden ich glaube
also wenn deine frage wer die
informationen ausreichen werden dann mit
die wählerschaft wirklich eine zu
erreichen begründete entscheidung
treffen kann
so würde ich sagen ja darin diese
voraussetzungen sind gegeben
sie begleiten wie du zu uns eigentlich
in ovaler weise du zu und sagen wir es
hier wie es ist dann bleiben wir uns
einfach auch dabei du bereitest die
us-politik ebenfalls seit vielen jahren
hat bis in den usa unter anderem auch
groß geworden was glaubst du wie sich
diese die aus wie die ereignisse der
letzten tage jetzt auf den wahlkampf aus
rücken werden
zunächst einmal muss ich auch sagen
natürlich ist jetzt das wichtigste dass
präsident trump wieder gesund wird und
da wünsche ich mir natürlich alles gut
und das ist sehr schnell passiert und
dass er vor allem wieder komplett gesund
wird jetzt ist im moment noch unklar wie
sich das auswirken würden ich habe hier
ja von einigen gästen schon gehört man
soll jetzt nicht spekulieren über den
gesundheitszustand aber was man
natürlich sagen muss ist dass die großen
spekulationen über den
gesundheitszustand von präsident trump
vom weißen haus selbst ausgelöst worden
weil es gab dort unterschiedliche
informationen teilweise gegensätzliche
informationen wie es präsident trump
eigentlich geht und natürlich bei einer
figur wie dem amerikanischen präsidenten
den mächtigsten mann der welt dem
entscheidungsträger wichtigsten
entscheidungsträger auf der welt ist es
natürlich ganz wichtig wie genau der
gesundheitszustand ist bei so einem
aggressiven virus wie den crooner virus
und da gab es ja am anfang auch die
aussagen von mitgliedern des teams des
weißen hauses dass es ihm eigentlich gut
geht dass er nicht beatmet wird dann
stellt sich heraus er ist doch beatmet
worden dass
sauerstoffgehalt in seinem blut
teilweise abgefallen ist all das macht
es natürlich schwierig und kann ihn dann
im endeffekt auch schaden
jetzt wo der wahl kann weiter geht also
es gab eine umfrage von nbc heute da lag
beiden bei 53 und trump bei 39 prozent
also es ist schon relativ große
unterschied zwischen den beiden und ist
es natürlich so dass wir seit 2016
wissen dass man den umfragen den usa
gerade nur bedingt trauen kann
und deswegen muss das nicht unbedingt
aussagekräftig sein
aber eins scheint doch der fall zu sein
dass der wahlkampf oder die wahl 2020
gewissen anteil wahrscheinlich nicht
sehr klein alter natürlich auch ein
referendum sein wird über die korona
virus politik von präsident trump und
von der tramp administration und da sind
natürlich einige fakten die die einfach
da sind also es sind einfach 200.000
menschen gestorben
in den vereinigten staaten es ist
natürlich auch gewohnter weise klein
geredet worden vom präsidenten und das
ist natürlich sachen die dann schon auch
nämlich die rolle spielen werden frau
bekommen sofort zu ihm bitte sehen sie
es mir nach dass ich noch einmal ganz
kurz an das was fremd gehen gerade
gesagt hat einmal noch mal kurz
medizinisch anschließen möchte und ich
habe gesehen dass funktionell mit dem
kopf geschüttelt hat hendrik strikt
möchte ich noch einmal ganz kurz ins
gespräch holen wenn der präsident seine
symptome am vergangenen freitag glaube
ich das erste mal wahrgenommen hat wie
lange typischerweise trägt man dieses
kroner virus dann schon in sich sind das
dann mehrere tage oder kann es sein dass
man schon am ersten tag der erkrankung
die symptome spürt ja also das ist
natürlich auch schwer zu sagen aber was
wir bisher wissen ist dass die
inkubationszeit ein bisschen thom
auftreten 56 tage dauern manchmal ein
bisschen kürzer manchmal ein bisschen
länger aber
im grunde muss man sagen dass das er das
dann so lange dann auch schon infiziert
gewesen ist das bedeutet aber nicht dass
er auch die gleichen zeitraum infektiös
gewesen ist das muss man unterscheiden
wann genau eine infektiosität auftritt
das es so noch nicht wirklich
nachgewiesen
gut möglich also dass der us präsident
schon seit längerer zeit mit dem corona
virus unterwegs ist wie queen hat eben
den kopf geschüttelt als gesprochen hat
aber es ist tatsächlich so dass es da
sehr widersprüchliche informationen bei
den ersten pressekonferenzen gab wie
lange der us-präsident das jetzt schon
hat 72 stunden 48 stunden
was können sie da zur aufklärung sagen
wir sollten uns daran erinnern dass die
medien auch nicht alles wissen ist sehr
viel spekulation im umlauf zu
verschiedenen aspekten die spekulationen
um exzessiven spekulationen haben die
verwirrung herbeigeführt
wir würden einfach sagen die medien
sollten sich erst mal einbringen es gibt
einfach bestimmte dinge wie sie nicht
erfahren
das ist der persönliche
gesundheitszustand eines menschen
sie interpretieren da allerlei in ein
was bedeutet sauerstoff was bedeutet
dass die wenige informationsfetzen diese
bekommen werden überinterpretiert ich
würde sagen man sollte sich etwas
zurücklehnen sich die videos von
präsident trump anschauen
das hören was er selbst sagt man bekommt
informationen direkt vom präsidenten
man bekommt vom weißen haus direkte
informationen zusätzliche verwirrung ist
dani nicht angezeigt die wenigen
informationen werden dann hin und her
geht es ja sie werden
warum interpretiert überinterpretiert
ich glaube wir verbringen alle zu viel
zeit damit dass der präsident eben im
video zu sehen war er sagte er habe
schwache symptome er ist in ärztlicher
obhut man versucht so vorsichtig wie
möglich vorzugehen und er ist
ab ich darauf schnell wieder zur arbeit
zurückzukehren wir sollten uns jetzt
nicht mit diesen spekulationen befassen
und tatsächlich politische themen
ansprechen und nicht die interpretation
dessen vorlegen was die medien tun sie
einer der wichtigsten verbündeten der
vereinigten staaten immer noch haben sie
sich in den letzten tagen gut informiert
gefühlt oder herrscht bei ihnen
unklarheit darüber wie es dem
us-präsidenten geht also ich glaube es
gibt viel unklarheit weil wir einfach
noch zu wenig über das virus wissen also
die frage wie lange die inkubationszeit
wann bricht die krankheit aus wie wie
ist der verlauf dann gab es
unterschiedliche informationen die dann
noch mal zu diskussionen geführt haben
ich glaube wir könnten noch zehn mal
sagen also schluss mit den spekulationen
natürlich wird immer weiter spekuliert
wird kann auch thema sagen aber dass die
theorie wird trotzdem haben sie das
gefühl sie wissen wie es dem
us-präsidenten geht also ich weiß das
was wir alle wissen
und natürlich werden wir über unsere
botschaft in washington auch auf dem
laufenden gehalten aber ich verfüge über
keine informationen
die gegenstand einer agenturmeldung
werden können so jetzt ist es wirklich
an der zeit einmal kamera wenn die aus
basel stürmer cavani sagt auch die wie
die medien über trump berichten und über
trump spekuliert haben ist nicht nur
besonders dienlich in so einer situation
frau wendi wie haben sie in den letzten
tagen die situation um donald von
beliebt ja also wie schon ihre jobs
cornelia sagt finde ich heute auch das
spekulieren rein gar nicht so viel
bringt aber man muss ja auch bedenken
dass über den gesundheitszustand der
kandidaten oder einer kandidatin ja viel
spekuliert wurde also bei beiden wegen
plakat auch bei es anders und auch
zuschauer natürlich bei hilary und ich
finde das ist vielleicht mal eine
gelegenheit sich zu fragen ist es
eigentlich sinnvoll dass
präsidentschaftskandidaten jenseits dass
sie dich oder jenseits der 75 je nachdem
überhaupt noch aufgestellt werden sollen
ich weiß es ist jetzt vielleicht ein
bisschen eine freche frage aber in der
vielleicht das jetzt mal die gelegenheit
diskutieren weil der eine seine
präsidentschaft ist eine enorme
körperliche und mentale anstrengung und
man sieht ja jetzt wie schnell das ganze
machtgefüge eigentlich verschoben werden
kann also vielleicht sollte man sich
auch mal diese frage stellen besondere
schmunzeln bei wolfgang ischinger der
uns vor der sendung verraten hat dass er
die versuche sich unser mann zu sein
derselbe jahrgang ist wie donald trump
deswegen gebe ich die frage einfach mal
an sie weiter und das ist ja tatsächlich
so dass amerika das oft für junge
kandidaten energiegeladene kandidaten
john f kennedy vermutlich für
deutschland dass das leuchten zum
beispiel stand da im moment zwei männer
im rennen hat die ich muss jetzt
wirklich laufpass er sich nicht unter
man werde aber einen großen teil ihres
lebens vielleicht schon vermutlich schon
gelebt haben ist das sinnvoll so so zu
nominieren na ja es ist so wie es ist
die beiden parteien haben ihre
kandidatenauswahl ihren primaries gehabt
und natürlich kann man lange darüber
nachdenken wie schön wäre es wenn wir
sagen wir mal ein 45 jähriger gegen eine
39 jährige antreten könnte wenn da
vielleicht auch mal eine frau jetzt
wieder antreten würde
aber es ist nun mal so die beiden sind
da ich würde ja nochmal auf diesen punkt
der transparenz oder der der der
unsicherheiten über diese krankheit wenn
etwas sagen
jede regierung hat wenn der
regierungschef oder wichtige minister
krank wird ein problem das problem ist
wie viel müssen wir sagen wir wollen ja
niemanden verunsichern wir wollen
stabilität eine stabilitäts botschaft
nach außen senden
ich denke die erfahrungen die wir alle
sammeln konnten mit erkrankungen von
deutschen politiker denken sie mal an
helmut schmidt denken sie mal an hans
dietrich genscher und viele andere
zurück und fälle in unseren
nachbarländern
das würde mich zu der empfehlung bringen
dass bei der abwägung alles dafür
spricht dass man möglichst transparent
also möglichst umfassend möglichst
korrekt
möglichst objektiv so berichtet dass
diese spekulation über die wir gerade
diskutiert jetzt ist schießen damit die
möglichst niedrig gehalten werden so zu
sagen was ich mir wünschen würde jetzt
so lange der präsident noch nicht wieder
voll im weißen haus ist jeden tag ein
bild aber nicht von irgendwelchen spin
doctors sondern von einem von einem
mandatierten chefarzt der als arzt seine
herzliche pflicht wahrnimmt und die
amerikanische bevölkerung und die
partner die von vom vom wohlergehen der
vereinigten staaten mit abhängig sind
objektiv unterrichtet ich glaube alles
andere führt dazu dass verschleierung
vorwürfe unsicherheiten entstehen und
das kann weder im interesse der
amerikanischen regierung sein und es ist
sicherlich nicht im interesse der
europäischen partner sehr enger
mitarbeiter von präsident rampen der
hochrangigen mitarbeiter hingegangen ist
zur waidhaus presse zu unserer presse
des weißen hauses und den anonym
informationen zugesteckt hat anonymous
source heißen dass dann die dann
natürlich darüber dann natürlich auch
berichtet wurde
und es ist ja dann auch am anfang so
gewesen dass man auch gesagt hat okay
hat ein paar milde symptome und dann hat
sich aber später herausgestellt man hat
sich da ja dort doch zu gewissen zeiten
schon relativ große sorgen gemacht und
ich glaube in diesem fall ist es nicht
so dass die spekulationen von der
uninformierten presse kommen sondern ich
glaube eher dass das große problem die
kommunikation des weißen hauses war in
diesem fall weil er einfach falsch
informationen zum teil weise verbreitet
wurden gegensätzliche informationen
verbreitet wurden informationen von
mitarbeitern des präsidenten verbreitet
wurden als anonyme informationen die
dann später aber das war nicht einmal
aufnehmen und dann mal gehört hab was
haben wir gesehen doctors oder spin
doctors was war ihr eindruck
was ist aber ich glaube dass das
grundsätzlich richtig dass leute wie wir
die ein öffentliches amt bekleiden
für die gelten andere kriterien als das
vielleicht normalerweise der fall ist
die leute haben ein recht darauf zu
wissen was ist mit einem los ist man in
der lage sein amt auszuüben
ich konnte auch nicht sagen ich
verschwinde jetzt mal für zehn tage in
quarantäne das geht keinen was an
sondern ich musste das rüsten sich an
die bild zeitung wenn sich geschichte
ich wusste dass öffentlich machen damit
die leute wissen was ist ich glaube dass
die leute auch ein anrecht darauf haben
ob man gesundheitlich in der lage ist
das amt das einem anvertraut worden ist
auch ausüben also insofern gelten für
uns da andere grenzen alles andere führt
dann nur zu mehr spekulationen und den
kann man am besten begegnen indem man
sehr sehr offen sehr transparent sagt
was ist man muss nicht die blutwerte
veröffentlichen
aber ich glaube die offenbar darum
andere ich darauf zu wissen ob man in
der lage ist zu regieren oder nicht es
ging ja tatsächlich um die blutung die
sauerstoffsättigung und gut wir reden ja
alle plötzlich über dinge von denen wir
zum chatten vorstellen können dass das
mal unser alltag ging es gegen auch um
die frage hat der präsident sauerstoff
bekommen
der arzt hat erst gesagt na hat er nicht
dann hat er sich bis auf die tage
bezogen am ende hat er doch sauerstoff
bekommt wie haben sie als bündnispartner
das wahrgenommen
in dieser weise informiert zu werden
durch die öffentlichkeit ehrlich gesagt
das was für mich entscheidend ist ist
wie es dem amerikanischen präsidenten
geht und welche auswirkungen das auf
seine administration hat auch seine
regierung
ob der an der sauerstoffflasche hin oder
nicht ist für mich primär nicht die
wichtigste botschaft sondern die
wichtigste botschaft geht es ihm gut
haben die ärzte die krankheit unter
kontrolle
würde alles für voll handlungsfähig
derzeit kann ich nicht beurteilen also
ich stehe nicht bei ihm am krankenbett
aber nach all dem was wir hören wird in
aussicht gestellt dass er in einigen
tagen wieder zurück ins büro kommen
könnte das wäre eine außerordentlich
gute entwicklung wir fragen einfach noch
einmal nach kalifornien zurück
und genau auf diese frage was ist da was
ist da passiert wir wissen ja bis heute
nicht ob der präsident zum beispiel
schon infiziert noch wahlkampf gemacht
hat es gibt dieses ereignis in new
jersey in seinem eigenen golf club in
dem er war von dem man bisher nicht weiß
hatte er da schon corona oder hatte er
ist
nicht weiß man darüber inzwischen mehr
gibt es darüber inzwischen klarheit
ich möchte darauf reagieren und auch
darauf fast schon gesagt sie haben hier
ein veganer den medien die züge der
zählung in der hand haben sie wollen
überall den daumen drauf haben sie haben
einige quellen zitiert sie zitieren
angeblich virtuellen aus dem weißen haus
sie packen dann allen möglichen
interpretationen darauf diese spärlichen
informationen die sie haben
vergleichen sie das mit den mehrfachen
videos die donald trump selbst
aufgenommen hat wir haben gesehen wie
donald trump das weiße haus verlassen
hat wir haben gesehen wie er mit eigenen
schiffen in das krankenhaus gelaufen ist
wir haben videos von inneren des
krankenhauses gesehen ein langes video
in dem er sich selbst äußerte das kann
man doch bewährte wie schaut jemand aus
wenn ein virus im körper trägt er war
sehr offen er war sehr redlich über
seinen zustand es gibt keinerlei
geheimniskrämerei was den medien nicht
behagt ist dass donald trump selbst der
videos an die öffentlichkeit richtet
dass er diese vollständige tanzbereich
selber herstellt oder von einer anderen
seite her betrachtet wenn es keinerlei
videos von präsident rand gäbe wenn wir
seine verfassungen nicht kennen würde
dann müssten wir uns auf die spekulation
der medien verlassen
die medien lieben diese macht nein das
ist ein dann berichtet sich direkt in
aller ehrlichkeit an die öffentlichkeit
er sagt genau was ist und was mit ihnen
geschehen ist
es ist schon lächerlich zu sehen wie wir
medien haben die jetzt irgendwie
versuchen sich die macht zurückzuerobern
die sie verloren haben mit allerlei
spekulationen mit anonymen quellen
während der präsident und das weiße haus
uns genug informationen geliefert haben
es wird einfach gesagt das ist eine
situation die im wandel es wir versuchen
transparent durch diese videos eher zu
stellen
beständige video berichterstattung sie
sehen dem präsidenten geht es ziemlich
gut sie sehen doch ja er hat eine kleine
infektion mit milden symptomen deskovic
wir beobachten in ostseenähe wir hoffen
dass in einigen wenig anfangen das ganze
vorbei
man hat in den letzten tagen das gefühl
dass es durchaus das ist ja eines der
wenigen worte deutschen worte die es in
die englische sprache geschafft haben
schadenfreude hier und da schadenfreude
darüber gab dass es jetzt donald trump
erwischt die tagesthemen haben zum
beispiel kommentiert man könnte das
durchaus als ich glaube die zynische
antwort der natur an donald trump für
seine verfehlte politik interpretieren
es gab von mehreren deutschen politikern
dinge die jetzt nicht nach aufrichtiger
anteilnahme klagen frau werden die
glauben sie in deutschland ist man
vielerorts ganz froh dass es donald
trump erwischt hat ja leider ist das ist
ja eigentlich
ich habe auch ziemlich viele tweets
gesehen von prominenten persönlichkeiten
publizisten mit großen accounts die da
gar keinen hehl daraus machen dass es
sich eigentlich freuten dass ich schon
mit der kommune - angesteckt hat und bin
ich ja eigentlich schrecklich weil egal
ob politische gegner oder nicht also der
anstand gebietet das doch dass man sagt
ich hoffe es geht ihm gleich mal wieder
weiter runter geht es gut und gute
besserung und alles andere ist halt
einfach wissen sie was mir halt auch
noch aufgefallen ist das sind ja
meistens dieselben leute die jetzt so
schadenfreudig über seine krankheit tun
diese sind jene die nation bei jeder
gelegenheit kritisieren und man kann
auch an ganz vielen punkten kann man ihn
kritisieren und muss man auch oder krise
nazismus wahrscheinlich größten absitzt
auf der welt rüpelhafte kerle rhetorik
spaltet mehr hast also leute
zusammenbringen aber dann muss man ihm
doch auch zugestehen er jetzt ist
frank ich wünsche ihm gute besserung ich
find das ist menschlich besonders in der
spd gab es und gibt es immer wieder
stimmen die sich sehr sehr sehr kritisch
mit der dort am auseinander setzen wir
wollen uns mal kurz einen tweet vom spd
gesundheitsexperten und einer der
lautesten stimmen kann man durchaus
sagen in der korona krise karl
lauterbach anschauen der getwittert hat
als arzt wünsche ich ja donald trump
natürlich alles gute aber politisch
hoffe er dass er die nächste zeit nicht
überlebt ist das der richtige gerade
dieses wort überlebt der richtige umgang
in so einer phase herr maas und kann man
vielleicht durchaus sagen sie haben die
tiefe einblicke das auch in der
deutschen politik
manche leute ja vielleicht mit
schadenfreude auf diese nachricht
reagiert haben dass donald trumps krone
hat naja das erleben wir ja täglich
natürlich ist es schrecklich wenn jemand
krank ist wenn das grund zur
schadenfreude ist aber ehrlich sind wenn
ich in die sozialen netzwerke gucke tag
für tag dort wird ständig hass und hetze
verbreitet und das trifft jetzt auch in
diesem fall zu und aber auch von der
lauterbach ist dass der ton den ist da
geben sollte und na ja also ich würde
hatte er immerhin gesagt dass er eben
gewünscht dass er relativ schnell wieder
gesund wird und diese äußerung dass er
sich wünscht dass er die wahl nicht
gewinnt hätte man vielleicht anders
formulieren können
aber wir erleben ja ganz andere sachen
in den sozialen netzwerken wie dort hass
und hetze verbreitet wird und das schade
der politischen kultur insgesamt und
dann müssen alle sich auch dazu die
frage gefallen lassen wer bis werden
nutzt das auch für seine zwecke aus
donald trump
na ja er ist auch einer das ist ja eben
auch schon mal gesagt worden der
polarisiert ich finde wenn es um solche
menschlichen vergleichen sommer sehr
zurückhaltend ausgedrückt das sehr
diplomatisch jemand wenn erkrankt wird
also wenn es um die person geht wenn es
ums überleben geht dann hat weder
schadenfreude irgendwie irgendeine
rechtfertigung noch sonst irgendwas aber
wie glaube wir müssen uns in diesem land
und nicht nur in diesem land mal
gedanken darüber machen was mit unserer
kommunikation wird denn so wie
kommuniziert wird über soziale netzwerke
glaube ich schade dass nicht nur der
kommunikation sondern am schluss auch
der demokratischen kultur auch bei uns
hier ein sprecher der vorgänger von
thomas im amt jetzt unser
bundespräsident ist hat donald trump ich
glaube noch vor amtsantritt ein
hassprediger
ich glaube nicht genannt sondern nennen
lassen damals über seine sprecherin ist
das nur dort vom schuld dass wir so
übereinander sprechen oder ist das
inzwischen sie kennen alle seiten auf
allen seiten so also ich bin der meinung
also minister mars hat ja recht was da
abläuft was da abgeht in den sozialen
netzwerken ist wirklich massiv unter der
gürtellinie
ich denke aber wenn wir vorhin uns einig
waren dass für den gesundheitszustand
führender politiker bis lande regeln
gelten als wesentliche privatpersonen
dann sollte das auch für die äußerungen
in sozialen netzwerken oder sonstige
öffentliche äußerung gelten also mir
wäre es lieber gewesen ich kann das
jetzt vielleicht etwas ungehemmter sagen
als als heiko maas mir wäre es lieber
gewesen gewesen herr lauterbach hätte
den zweiten satz seines tritts
weggelassen und hätte den präsidenten
einfach gute genesung gewünscht und dies
den satz mit dem überleben weggelassen
denn wir müssen natürlich schon seit
sehen wenn ein führender politiker sich
so einlässt dann darf man sich nicht
wundern dass seine eigenen follower
seine politischen freunde denken ja wie
das so erlaubt ist dann kann ich nochmal
eins drauflegen
also wir machen es nicht besser wenn wir
jetzt sozusagen wie die politische
klasse sagt ja trump benimmt sich ja
selber ständig daneben dann können wir
uns jetzt auch mal ein bisschen daneben
benehmen ich finde eben gerade nicht
lasst uns in würde
carlson vorgang behandeln das hilft
vielleicht auch für die allgemeine würde
der debatte in deutschland und darüber
hinaus mahnende worte von wolfgang
ischinger würden sie sich den
anschließenden auch in die richtung der
eigenen partei genossen und genossinnen
und das gilt ja für alle also das gibt
es ja nicht nur diejenigen die in der
spd sind sondern es geht uns alle an das
geht auch die an
selbst wenn man krank wird wird man an
dem gemessen was man vorher getan hat
und ich glaube für uns auch da gelten
andere regeln wir haben eine
vorbildfunktion und wenn sich bei dem
was wir artikulieren völlig unabhängig
davon
auf welchem medium oder auf welchem
kanal uns immer mehr gehen lassen auch
sprachlich da mussten wir uns nicht
wundern dass das die allgemeinheit auch
tut weil sie denken wenn die das können
dann ist es auch für uns erlaubt ich
weiß nicht ob sie das schöne deutsche
wort schadenfreude in ihren jahren hier
in berlin schon wahrgenommen haben aber
es scheint ja durchaus zutreffen in
dieser zeit ich habe hier eben karl
lauterbach genannt spd
gesundheitsexperte der gesagt hat er
hoffe dass trump diese zeit politisch
nicht überleben
ist das tatsächlich aus ihrer sicht ein
angemessener ton aus deutschland ich
glaube sollte das nicht kritisieren
wenn jemand sich so leidenschaftlich
äußert über seine antipathie gegenüber
donald trump wir brauchen
der button wir brauchen eine offene
debatten wo die menschen ganz offen
miteinander reden
wir müssen aber auch imstande seien auch
die damon selbst anzusprechen
die politische klasse aus dem häuschen
darüber weil präsident kantine zu den
leuten selbst richtung nicht zur
politischen klasse
er spricht also nicht nur zu sein ist
gleich und ich möchte erinnern was
beiden gemacht hat in dieser letzten
debatten
also ich zutiefst angegriffen als person
donald trump dagegen hatte natürlich joe
biden gegenüber auch sehr hart zur sache
geredet ja tacheles geredet zu
politischen themen
wir sind hier eine arten politischen
debatte das ist ja unbestritten aber
alle die hier zu schauen
googeln sie doch mal bitte bei der
debatte gegen pauli und 2012er hat die
neue stelle und da brauchen die beiden
haben
da nicht unter beim city night line live
unseren samstagabendshow hat mit joggen
sich einen heidenspaß gemacht und die
politische klasse ignoriert das
fehlverhalten von joe biden
wir sollten auch eines ganz klar sagen
die politische klasse in berlin dass die
republikaner und die konservativen sich
alle rollen skript alten tut mir leute
wenn wir gewinnen müssen wir ebenso klar
für unsere sache eintreten wie andere
das tun hatten
joe biden hat wirklich vier mal ganz
gern hat gesagt ein idiot ein rassist er
sollte endlich die klappe halten also
dass es doch wirklich überhaupt nicht
wer ignoriert denn das nun die
öffentlichkeit nimmt das tor in
pennsylvania in ohio eine wahl da da
trete ich alle diese echten
authentischen meinungsäußerung von
führenden repräsentanten die amerikaner
lieben an ihren präsidenten das erkämpft
wir scheuen davor nicht zurück es ist
ganz wichtig einen konservativen einen
republikaner der kampf bereit ist zu
haben und der sich nicht wegduckt
politischen klasse in washington von dem
was man dort so von einem präsidenten
erwartet angesprochen hat man das waren
die worte des demokratischen kandidaten
joe biden an der donald trump ort wie
man sie in einer präsidentschafts
debatte vermutlich noch nie gehört hat
und das wollen wir uns jetzt noch einmal
anschauen ist dies der schlechteste
präsident den amerikaner hatte
ich trage eine maske wenn es nötig ist
ich trage die maske nicht so wie er
jedes mal wenn man ihn sieht trägt er
eine maske
er kann 60 meter entfernt von mir reden
und er taucht mit der größten maske auf
die tatsache ist alles was er bisher
gesagt hat ist einfach eine lüge
alle wissen kannst du die klappe halten
man das ist sowas von nicht präsidial
ist dass der ton an dem wir uns jetzt
gewöhnen müssen ich hoffe mich ehrlich
gesagt denn das was man da gesehen hat
ist vor allen dingen eines nämlich
respektlos und respektlos von beiden
seiten mit also das würde wohl dein
iphone weiß haben jetzt beide dieses
duell bestritten und haben beide sich
irgendwann auf einem niveau eingependelt
von dem wagen würde dass leute die
präsident werden wollen in den
vereinigten staaten
auch wenn es dem einen oder anderen
schwer fällt nicht so miteinander
umgehen sollten denn auch das wird ja
gesehen und auch das wird von anderen
dann übernommen
[Musik]
deshalb würde ich mir wünschen dass es
noch ein duell gibt in dem die beiden
zeigen dass es auch eine andere
politische kultur in den vereinigten
staaten gibt
da werden die wie kommen ihnen dieses
duell vw zwei gorillas oder wie zwei
menschen die us präsident werden wollen
die zwei gorillas ich schon ganz aktuell
oder zumindest strecken heißt es aktuell
geschehen da wollen also zwei gestandene
männer präsidenten werden aber schaffen
es nicht eine zivilisierte debatte zu
führen also die amerikaner tun allem ein
bisschen leid im moment bin ich ein
großer fan von amerika oder aber hier
ich persönlich auch nachdem ich das
gesehen habe ich heute für unwählbar
aber vielleicht sollten wir ja auch mal
überlegen oder wir müssen uns vielleicht
mal fragen warum sind denn die
amerikaner überhaupt an diesem punkt
angelangt also vor allem am ball er ist
ja ein symptom für etwas oder
also warum hat man ihn dann überhaupt
option jetzt hat man so viele probleme
mit ihm warum haben so viele menschen
denn damals überhaupt gewählt oder
diesen rüpel und jetzt anschlussstellen
dann diese beiden übrig also was ist da
schief gelaufen in dem land ich finde
diese frage eigentlich noch ziemlich
interessant oder vielleicht ist ja auch
eine art phänomen das man ernst nehmen
muss oder was ist in amerika da passiert
was man am schluss einfach trapp gewählt
haben oder dass man ihm zutraut okay er
hilft uns jetzt aber er steht uns bei
gegen das politische establishment oder
vielleicht auch gegen die medien aber
finde das muss man halt schon ein
bisschen genauer anschauen oder jetzt
nicht nur sich so auf die partie
konzentrieren und vielleicht hat er da
welche thunell eine erklärung dafür
ich würde trotzdem gern noch einmal kurz
zu verkommen glaubst du dass das bei
einem zweiten duell zivilisierter zu
gehen wollte man hat ja schon das gefühl
die beiden konnten eigentlich gar nicht
so richtig raus aus ihrer seele das war
die berner schulhof schlägerei die
vorher ausgemachte sache war es hat zehn
sekunden gedauert und warum sind beide
aufeinander losgegangen
das graue ich glaube dass das trump das
gemacht hat was er immer macht er
versuchte unruhe zu stiften
was sicherlich dann mitteilen zu weit
gegangen ist aber natürlich muss man von
jemandem wie joe biden dann auch
erwarten dass er da nicht unbedingt sich
dann aus der reserve locken lässt
es ist ja auch in den usa danach zur
kenntnis genommen worden dass eine
debatte in dieser form nie wieder so
stattfinden darf also es ist ja von von
diversen experten von den medien von den
leuten ja auch selbst die debatte
organisieren gesagt worden man muss da
andere regeln machen ich glaube presse
den tramp wehrt sich dagegen dass die
regeln sich ändern sollen
vizepräsident biden bin ich mir nicht
sicher ob er sich darauf einlassen würde
aber es gibt schon die überlegung dass
sich da irgendwas ändern muss aber es
ist natürlich in der tat so dass der
politische diskurs in den usa natürlich
einfach mit extrem harten bandagen und
immer härteren bandagen geführt wird von
herrn greene l gehört dass er sich da
ein bisschen aufgeregt hat wie joe biden
präsident scharf angegangen dass man
darf natürlich nicht vergessen dass
präsident schrammt sich im dauerfeuer
eigentlich darüber lustig gemacht hat
dass joe biden angeblich nur in seinem
keller sitzt das joe biden immer seine
maske trägt jetzt sitzt präsident jobs
selbst da und hat corona virus hat in
sleepy
joe biden genannt ich meine es ist das
ist ein fortwährendes dauerfeuer gewesen
und und ich glaube schon dass es viele
auch in den usa gibt die sagen dass das
die art wie zur zeit der wahlkampf dort
geführt wird wirklich für das volk auch
nicht wirklich viel gewinn bringt also
gerade diese debatte war wirklich echt
glaube ich hoffentlich ein weckruf für
für die politische klasse wolfgang
ischinger hat sich auf twitter gewünscht
oder zumindest angekündigt dass er sich
auf joe biden bei den nächsten
sicherheitskonferenz freut was nicht bei
allen kramp anhängern besonders gut
angekommen ist
freuen sie sich nach diesem auftritt
nach chapman immer noch auf ihn
naja wir laden also zunächst mal sagen
wir laden regelmäßig standardmäßig
natürlich den amerikanischen präsidenten
sein vize präsident und sein
außenminister und verteidigungsminister
ein
wir haben donald trump und sein vize
denn die ganzen letzten jahre eingeladen
erfreulicherweise ist wie zb pence zwei
mal erschien joe biden ist ein alter
bekannter der sich der war schon als
senator da dann war zweimal als
vizepräsident da in seiner
vizepräsidentschaft zeiten ist jetzt als
ex-vizepräsident auch nochmal gekommen
also ich würde mich über jeden der im
nächsten jahr verantwortung hat entweder
in der regierung oder im senat oder war
immer freuen weil wir diese gespräche in
münchen brauchen
ich will noch wenn ich darf noch eine
anmerkung machen zu diese zusage zur zu
derart weise wie amerikaner mit dieser
debatte umgehend also ich teile die
meinung dass war entwürdigend und so wie
ich meine amerikanischen freunde kenne
ich habe ja selbst relativ viele jahre
in amerika gelebt
die haben eigentlich alle einen ziemlich
tief verwurzelten sinn für fairness und
ich glaube dass für viele normale
amerikaner dieses schauspiel was ihnen
angeboten worden ist dass ihnen das
wirklich
das dass sie das abschreckend finden
dass sie das abscheulich finden das sich
eigentlich wünschen dass hier zwei
präsidentschaftskandidaten vernünftig
über sachthemen miteinander diskutieren
ich glaube also nicht dass trump und ich
glaube übrigens auch nicht dass beiden
wirklich gewinnen kann durch diese form
der auseinandersetzung die ist lass es
mich mehr so formulieren ich weiß ihre
kriminellen damit was anfangen kann
ich finde diese form der
auseinandersetzung zutiefst
unamerikanisch eigentlich unamerikanisch
fast gar nicht wir wollen uns noch
einmal ganz kurz anschauen was ihr
parteikollege olaf scholz über die
bevorstehende wahl gesagt hat und wen er
im wahlkampf unterstützt
drücken sie die beiden die daumen dass
er gewinnt ja das tue ich als bürger
dieser welt und als jemand der natürlich
auch politisch für ein programm steht
das darauf gerichtet ist dass wir
vernünftig miteinander in der welt
umgehen und dass wir gleichzeitig in
unsere länder versöhnen und nicht
spalten damals wem drücken sie als
bürger dieser welt und als außenminister
dieses landes dass weitere ankündigung
also ich bin hier eingeladen als
außenminister dieses landes und als
außenminister hält man sich aus
wahlauseinandersetzung bundeskanzler
nicht
ich bin hier als außenminister und als
außenminister hält man sich raus weil
ich angst dass irgendeine interessieren
wird in den vereinigten staaten wenig
lieber hätte das was mich interessiert
ist dass die branche die ist im deutsch
amerikanischen verhältnis und in der
transatlantische partnerschaft gibt
zwischen den usa und der europäischen
union dass das wieder besser wird und
aber sollte sich ein vizekanzler da so
festlegen dann wird schon seine gründe
dafür haben wir können etwas server
glauben sie was denken sie wenn sie
hören dass der vizekanzler der vize chef
der deutschen bundesregierung ja auch so
klar sagt als bürger dieser welt und
damit ihr deutlich macht dass man sich
als bürger dieser welt eigentlich gar
nichts anderes wünschen kann als dass
donald trump die wahl verliert was sagen
sie dazu
zunächst einmal zwei allererste
dann hätten wir eine dreijährige
ermittlungen laufen wegen der
einrichtung der russen in amerikanische
wahlkämpfe was aber tun das gilt als pro
ps oder als recht behördlich vielleicht
darf ich nur darauf antworten
dieser gedanke das ist ein durchbruch im
transatlantischen zeit nicht geben
ich glaube das nicht ich glaube was die
regierung trump versuch zu bewirken ist
dass sie es klar feststellen dass die
amerikaner ein großer verbündeter
unserer freunde in deutschland waren wir
lieben die deutschen millionenfach habe
ich das gesagt es gibt so viele menschen
die weiterhin zu deutschland bekennen
diese die heiraten auch nach deutschland
sie haben vielfältige verbindungen und
holt sie nach deutschland
das ist auch einer der gründe weshalb
die regierung treffe sich ganz klar für
die transatlantischen beziehungen
einsetzt dass eben die europäischen
verbündeten sich abwenden von
sozialistischen von global ist ischen
ideen dieses bündnis das eben ein auf
westlichen werten begründer des
bündnisses begründet auf der
rechtsstaatlichkeit
da sollte man nicht nur neun tage lang
überlegen auf welche seite man in
venezuela steht man sollte wirklich
eindeutig sich zur westbindung beginnen
wir glauben in der regierung kommt dass
in den letzten jahren sicherlich in den
letzten acht jahren der regierung obama
biden dass die europäer sicheren weg
bewegt haben vom kapitalismus weg bewegt
haben von einer starken westlichen
allianz
wir dürfen natürlich diese debatte
führen wohin sollte sich das westliche
bündnis bewegen
wir sind der meinung wir sind ja aus dem
tritt geraten wir sollten wieder ganz
klare zu westlichen werten uns bekennen
diese transatlantische bündnis kraft
stärken wir glauben nicht dass das
irgendwie alle in europa sich doch hin
zum sozialismus bewegen sollten
ich denke wir sollten mehr sorgfalt
darauf verwenden dass wirklich die
westliche verankerung demokratie
kapitalismus rechtsstaatlichkeit das
sind die pfeiler
ich würde meinen dass sie den tramp hält
sich also ganz stark gebunden an diese
werte
er sieht also dieses problem einer
aufspaltung oder eines
auseinanderdriftens der natur lassen sie
mich auch sagen die nato ist das
bedeutendste großartigste bündnis in der
weltgeschichte aber dieses das ist etwas
in schieflage geraten und ist sozusagen
vom rechten kurs abgekommen
wir legen größten wert auf diese
beziehung wir wollen auch dass jeder
partner seine last treibt und das waren
diese verpflichtungen ernst nimmt und
auch erfüllt ich würde sagen ja wir
lieben diese transatlantische bündnis
kraft wir wollen eine starke machtvolle
als land des kreistags helm gesagt hat
wir lieben die deutschen warum bringt
sie das inzwischen zum lachen würden wir
gerne noch etwas mehr von dieser liebe
fühlen und ich glaube dass es richtig
ist dass es gefühlen sie nicht genug
liebe außen also irgendwie wenn man wenn
man gegenseitig strafzölle verhängt auf
aluminium und stahl wenn man nicht mehr
gleiche position vertritt un abkommen
die man mal gemeinsam geschlossen hat
dann kann man ja nicht sagen dass alles
so ist wie es sein sollte und wenn ein
amerikanischer präsident sagt die gegner
der vereinigten staaten sind russland
china und europa dann finde ich bilde
das auch nicht unbedingt das ab was ich
unter liebe verstehe aber wir wollen
auch dass die transatlantische
partnerschaft auch die zusammenarbeit in
der nato ich bin eher froh dass nach
einigem hin und her auch in washington
man sich zur nato bekannt hat so gab es
auch einige diskussionen
also wir brauchen diese zusammenarbeit
will haben wir sind eigentlich werte
partner wir sind liberale demokratien
und wir wollen uns mit den werten die
wir haben und natürlich auch mit den
interessen auf der welt behaupten können
und das können wir nur zusammen wobei
man dazusagen muss die vereinigten
staaten haben ihre politik als der
weltpolizist er sie mal gewesen sind
stück für stück zurückgefahren das ist
auch ihr gutes recht
und das wird dazu führen dass wir gar
nicht darum herumkommen ich glaube im
übrigen das ist gar nicht so sehr
abhängig sein wird wer die nächste wahl
gewinnen wird sondern wir in europa
werden uns darauf einstellen müssen dass
wir uns dass wir mehr verantwortung
übernehmen müssen auch international als
wir das vielleicht aus der vergangenheit
gewohnt und das ist der teil den wir bei
tragen müssen
aber ich würde mir schon wünschen dass
auch auf der anderen seite des atlantik
dieser teil dazu beigetragen wird und
wir aufhören uns gegenseitig mit
entscheidungen zu über 10 sanktionen
strafzöllen sondern dass wir die
gemeinsamkeiten betonen ich glaube wir
haben nur positiv agenda auf beiden
seiten des atlantiks und wir müssen die
auch wieder viel stärker
operationalisieren und realisieren
wolfgang ischinger heiko maas möchte das
deutsch amerikanische verhältnis wieder
gestärkt sehen
jetzt sehen wir mal ein beispiel
truppenabzug seit jahrzehnten wird in
deutschland gerufen ami go home
in manchen parteien mehr in manchen
partien weniger dann geht der ami hormon
dann sagen die haben ja regen sagen die
deutschen ihr könnt doch nicht herum
gehen sind wir vielleicht ein bisschen
selber schuld
naja also die die frage ob wir jetzt
40.000 oder 20.000 amerikanischen
soldaten auf deutschem boden brauchen
das halte ich für die zentralste
strategische frage was aber unglück
selig war bei diesem vorgang ist dass er
nicht richtig konsultiert worden ist im
grunde kam das zumindest beim einem
deutschen publikum so an
da hat da ist irgendwas missfallen in
washington und jetzt kriegen die
deutschen mal sozusagen eine
übergebraten und wir zehnmal 12.000 mann
ab nicht schön
das problem was ich sehe ist in der
diplomatie in den internationalen
beziehungen in den transatlantischen
beziehungen ist die
ehrung dieser beziehung das vertrauen
das bestand über all diese regierung
eisenhower reagan clinton obama mehr
oder weniger werden immer krisen aber
wir hatten ein grundvertrauen und mir
scheint dass in den letzten jahren aus
kunden die vielleicht auch auf
europäischer seite lagen ja nicht so
dass immer nur die eine seite
schuld an allem ist das vertrauen ist
aber in wesentlichen teilen kaputt
gegangen das muss wieder aufgebaut
werden
das aufbauen wenn jemand wie herr
mützenich donald trump einen rassisten
nennt ist das dienlich um dieses
verhältnis weiter zu stärken oder wieder
aufzubauen
ich glaube es geht darum dass in denen
themen in denen wir zusammen aber es
gibt viele themen also wenn ich mir
anschaue
aber der fällt zusammenarbeit ja schwer
wenn ich jemand den rassisten nenne man
möchte ja eigentlich kennen wir mit dem
arbeiten wenn man davon überzeugt ist
dass das wirklich so ist dann auch nicht
so tun als als dass donald trump jemand
wäre der nicht auch dinge in die welt
posaunt die man hinterfragen muss auch
in der wortwahl
ich glaube es wird darum gehen die dinge
wo wir zusammenarbeiten auch positive
beispiele in afghanistan haben die
vereinigten staaten mit dem agreement
dass sie mit den taliban geschlossen
haben jetzt dafür gesorgt dass eine
friedens konnte sich das träumen lassen
dass ein tier mit den taliban eine
positive nachricht ist als kurt beck spd
vorsitzender war und sagte man muss mit
den taliban verhandeln ist so glaube ich
irgendwie anschließend als nicht mehr
ganz zurechnungsfähig zumindest außen
dabei hätte es von gott her gepasst aber
nur dieses beispiel zu vollenden die
amerikaner haben das getan und jetzt
gibt es die friedensverhandlungen die
amerikaner haben uns gebeten zusammen
mit den norwegern diese
friedensverhandlungen federführend zu
übernehmen alle hatten die eigentlichen
auf dem petersberg stattfinden
die abschließende runde na ja die haben
jetzt in doha in katar angefangen die
werden weiter fortgesetzt werden wo das
der fall sein wird wird das bei bonn
ich will ja gar keine option in die welt
hinausposaunen das ist dann wirklich
sehr sehr sensibler verhandlungsprozess
wichtig ist dass man sich verständigt
völlig unabhängig davon wo aber wir
werden zusammen mit norwegen dort ganz
federführend mit dabei sein
zum abschluss noch mal eine ganz
zentrale frage der vergangenen woche
in diesem transatlantischen verhältnis
fremd ist korrespondent fürs hirn in
moskau und da geht es ja im moment immer
tatsächlich um das spannungsverhältnis
wie im kalten krieg zwischen washington
und moskau wenige kilometer von hier ich
habe ihn am wochenende zufällig im park
getroffen gegen hannover lni mit seiner
familie glücklicherweise mit seinem sohn
spazieren wieder auf den beinen aber nur
weil deutsche erziehen im letzten moment
gerettet haben können wir uns wirklich
in die hände von leuten begeben mit
etwas wie nord stream 2 die weltweit
nervenkampf stoffe einsetzen um ihre
oppositionellen auf ekelhafteste weise
zu vergiften die im tiergarten wenige
hundert meter von ihrem amt entfernt vom
auswärtigen amt den fachleuten den kopf
schießen lassen können wir uns so in
deren hände begeben dass wir uns auf
etwas wie nord stream 2 für unsere
energiesicherheit verlassen oder ist das
natürlich eine frau an die amerikaner
also zunächst mal muss man sagen dass
zum beispiel die vereinigten staaten im
letzten jahr ihre schweröl importe aus
russland in die usa verdoppelt haben sie
sind jetzt der zweitgrößte schwere
ölimporteur aus russland also wenn man
die vergleichsmaßstäbe anlegt dann bitte
für alle wichtig ist dass so etwas und
wir haben das nachgeprüft und haben
festgestellt dass es sich um ein
kampfstoffe nervengift aus der november
gruppe handle das wird zurzeit von der
organisation die das chemie waffen
übereinkommen überprüft jetzt noch
einmal analysiert und wenn die
ergebnisse vorliegen werden wir in
europa darauf reagieren müssen aber wir
sind ja in europa schon alleine im
prinzip mit nord stream also ganz
konkret die frage sollte deutlich sagen
sie sind über 100 europäische firmen an
diesem projekt beteiligt die hälfte aus
deutschland was regierungen angeht gab
es da massiven widerspruch gegen lotte 2
und es wird inzwischen getragen von
deutschland aber ich meine ganz konkret
an sie persönlich die frage
wir haben es mit leuten zu tun die
vergiften sie indem sie etwas an den
kragen schmieren sollten wir von diesen
menschen noch gas kauft warum kaufen die
vereinigten staaten dann immer das ist
sogar schwer ist daran so schwer
schweröl als sie das davor getan haben
also ich bitte dann aber mal die
gleichen maßstäbe sind ja das eine aber
was sind ihre maßstäbe die maßstäbe sind
die dass das was geschehen ist mit herrn
avni konsequenzen bedarf so und wenn wir
die ergebnisse
vcw vorliegen haben wird ist diese
konsequenzen auch geben ist ein nord
stream zwei motoren zb eine mögliche
konsequenz
darüber werden wir mit unseren
europäischen partnern zu reden haben
denn wir sind ja es ist ja kein russisch
deutsche bilateraler konflikt sondern
wir sind ja nur der überbringer der
schlechten nachricht ist muss daraus
eine europäische reaktion geben und
darüber werden wir mit unseren
europäischen partnern zu lesen du kennst
dieses regime red du lebst in moskau
glaubst du dass sich dort etwas ändern
wird an der art und weise wie moskau mit
anderen ländern umspringt ob das jetzt
attentate sind oder hacking kampagnen
gegen waren zb wenn man dort nicht an
sondern stelle mal sehr klare kante
zeigt also es gibt zumindest nicht
anschein das ist ja irgendetwas ändert
wenn sich etwas ändert vielleicht eher
in die andere richtung das ist er noch
und noch mehr in die hotline richtung
geht also man sich jetzt so anguckt die
regierung putin in den letzten paar
jahren ist ja viele konflikte auf einmal
eingegangen jetzt weißrussland war ja
auch so ein beispiel in weiß was das ist
ja völlig klar dass die breite mehrheit
der leute dort lukaschenko ablehnen
völlig klar
millionen menschen sind auf die straße
gegangen in vielen städten und putin
also jetzt hat er zu ihnen reißen lassen
lukaschenko zu unterstützen obwohl er
ihn nicht mal gegen das gegen das volk
in weißrussland also insofern dass man
da ecke und man hat ja auch die
reaktionen auf der bahn versucht es
jetzt den deutschen in die schuhe zu
schieben da gibt es ja die wüsten
spekulation also insofern dass sich da
etwas tut ist jetzt im moment nicht zu
erkennen und wladimir putin hat ja auch
eine verfassungsänderung durchgedrückt
die ermöglichen könnte das ja glaub ich
bis 83 im amt bleiben könnte
was soll sich da ändern also insofern
ist das im moment sicherlich sehr
schwierig und dass man da erkennen
könnte dass es irgendwie eine neue
politik gibt also jetzt im moment ist
das schwierig zu erkennen
damit kommen wir zu unserer
abschließenden fragerunde und ich würde
sie gerne bei unserem medizinischen
experten beginnen der die ganze zeit uns
begleitet hat wenn auch ein bisschen aus
dem off und zwar ist diese frage ganz
einfach wer gewinnt die amerikanische
wal und vor allem warum bitte um kurze
antworten professor
was glauben sie wer gewinnt die us fall
und warum mit der frage habe ich jetzt
nicht gerechnet das ist auf jeden fall
keine medizinische frage aber ich kann
mir gut vorstellen dass trump die wahl
gewinnen wird weil tochter große
rückhalt des abends
und noch eine medizinische frage an sie
nachgereicht professor schräg glauben
sie dass sonne und morgen wieder im oval
office sitzt
das ist schwer zu sagen also das ja rein
spekulativ die ärzte haben gesagt er
würde in oberhof sitzen aber medizinisch
ist wahrscheinlich besser wenn er auch
sich noch mehr ausprobieren würde aber
aus japan über diese meilen über den
ozean ist es wirklich schwer zu sagen
tamara werden die welt us-präsident oder
wer bleibt us-präsident und warum
da habe ich keine ahnung da möchte ich
auch gar keine prognose stellen wolfgang
ischinger mit der ausrede kommen sie
nicht davon dass sie keine ahnung haben
also ihr tipp
ja aber eine andere ausrede ich habe als
diplomat seit den zeiten von jimmy
carter immer mitwirken müssen an
prognosen für den damaligen
außenminister für die bundesregierung
und ich muss hier ich sag's öffentlich
gestehen ich lag ich persönlich immer
falsch aber dann sind wenn ich jetzt
sage wir liegen hoch wie an anderen
sarah sartor welche zeit ich habe den
eindruck dass möglicherweise wegen der
ganzen corona vorgänger möglicherweise
das pendeln jetzt doch eher in richtung
beiden gehen könnte dann hoffe ich dass
ich nicht wieder falsch liege mit der
falschen prognose also ich bin da kein
besonders zuverlässiger wahrsager so
darf man bei wolf kein geschenk jetzt
mal live sehen können was die ganz feine
schule der diplomatie weiß wie man dinge
wie man dinge ausdrückt und damit kommen
wir zur regional der vermutlich auch
sehr diplomatisch sagen wird wer gewinnt
die wahl und warum also ich meine
einsätze und winter geben habe an sechs
präsidentenwahl kämpfen teilgenommen ich
habe die umfrage in europa gesehen
die deutschen medien berichten ganz
häufig über landesweite umfragen wir
haben
aber keine landesweite wahl sondern es
ist eine im einzel staaten gegliederte
wahl sie müssen also zweierlei im auge
behalten erster oslo
wohin gehen die kandidaten das
vermittelt einen guten eindruck
hinsichtlich der zwischenergebnisse die
beiden in florida in ohio habe ich kaum
wahrgenommen
er geht an orte wo er eigentlich schon
die ernte hätte einfahren müssen
bei den anschein sie sorgt sie darauf
dass manche eben nervös werden
hinsichtlich ihrer stammwählerschaft
trump geht dagegen nach starten wie
minnesota englich keine bollwerke der
republikaner sind
ich werde jetzt unsere internen umfrage
ergebnisse nicht preisgeben ich bin aber
zuversichtlich
diese begeisterung die ich vor ort sind
und ich habe diese authentischen bilder
der einfachen amerikaner ja gezeigt
menschen die zum beispiel an der
straßenecke stehen
es gibt sogar boots demonstrationen für
trump das lässt sich mit händen greifen
diese begeisterung für trump in eugen in
kalifornien
da habe ich eine autokolonne gesehen
zwischen geschmückt flaggen so etwas
geschick bei joe biden nicht schauen sie
sich mal diesen einsatz der räder an die
führt ernst das muss man mal vor augen
hat wer lässt sich wirklich begeistern
die begeisterung für trump ist sehr viel
höher als die für joe biden empfehlung
ist eine wette würde ich auch nicht
machen weil ich glaube ich habe einfach
mein tipp ich habe überhaupt gar keine
ahnung also es ist ganz ehrlich so ich
habe überhaupt gar keine ahnung wer
diese wahl gewinnen wird weil es sehr
schwierig ist jetzt moment nach den
umfragen zu gehen ich glaube nur eine
sache ganz deutlich dass die
entscheidung sicherlich ganz ganz spät
erst fallen
für viele viele leute ich glaube es gibt
sehr sehr viele leute die die noch
unentschlossen sind
ich glaube sie jetzt sehr sehr spät
herausstellen welche richtung das ganze
geht und ich glaube das ist wirklich
wahrscheinlich darauf ankommt wer in den
letzten tagen nochmal meisten
mobilisieren kann der wird dann
sicherlich die besten chancen aber es
ist im moment wirklich unmöglich da eine
prognose abzugeben
damals wir hatten jetzt einmal dass es
keine medizinische frage 2 weil ich habe
keine ahnung einmal bei mir kommt immer
das gegenteil heraus von dem was ich
prognostiziere
alle warten jetzt gespannt was tippt der
deutsche aussenminister und es ist
ausdrücklich um es ihm leichter zu
machen es ist ausdrücklich kein wunsch
keine empfehlung es ist nur ihr tipp
also erstmal schön groß am reck nach
kalifornien du bist als wahlkämpfer
jeden cent wert so die frage die frage
bei der frage verweigere ich
berufsbedingt die aussage sage aber zu
mit jedem gewählten präsidenten daran zu
arbeiten dass aus der
deutsch-amerikanischen liebe etwas
wieder wird der deutsche außenminister
verspricht am ende dieses sonntags abend
mehr liebe was könnten wir uns alle noch
mehr wünschen vielen dank dass sie
zugeschaut haben hierbei bild bei die
richtigen fragen danke an unsere gäste
nach basel und nach kalifornien und
danke ihnen allen heute abend hier im
studio und damit einen schönen
sonntagabend in allen zu hause noch und
bis nächste woche
vielen dank
[Musik]